[Music]
okay tell me real quick
the most romantic thing like the most
romantic thing he's ever done for you
and then what she's ever done for you
well I mean he's done so much but I do
think that the couple of letters that
he's written to me have been the best
you've done so much that has made me
feel so lucky I told him my perfect
night of a date was watching Superman
ordering Chinese food and having red
wine and then like a week later she
texted me a picture of her watching
Superman eating Chinese food drinking
red wine and then I knew that I need to
marry this woman okay so you're gonna
marry this woman yeah
at some point oh my I'm still trying to
find that the bite-mark from the Love
Bug I don't know where it is Ashley I
know you're a romantic person have you
thought about what your wedding dress is
gonna be oh well I you know it's funny
he'll watch say yes the dress with me
it's actually crazy
what's up by choice I know I asked him
like do you like vag you like the
princess gowns you like a mermaid a
fit-and-flare we definitely know that we
don't like finding flair okay so you
thought about this yes
[Music]